while 2017 brought us a bunch of awesome
new tech that includes the Xbox 1x
antenna switch and more there's always
more room for technological improvement
with that said here are all the hardware
and gadgets we want to see in 2018 4k
displays are a burgeoning market but
there are currently no 4k high refresh
rate monitors that's something that
should change in 2018 as we'd like to
see 120 Hertz offerings in the 2160p
space that you can game with higher
frame rates you will need a super beefy
graphics card to power that which leads
us to the next thing we want to see in
2018 we want to see Nvidia's new Volta
based GeForce GPUs the company recently
launched its $3,000 Titan V GPU based on
its new microarchitecture and the card
is capable of delivering 110 teraflops
of performance but it's super expensive
and is designed for data scientists
hopefully the Titan V paves the way for
Volta based GeForce cards geared towards
gamers in 2018 while you can get HDR
OLED TVs there aren't any HDR old at
gaming monitors hopefully that changes
in 2018 HDR would allow gaming monitors
to feature more vibrant colors and OLED
panels would ensure true black levels
with their individually backlit pixels
Ami's 2017 released Rx vega 64 and 56
are good high-end cards but the company
still doesn't have anything to compete
against Nvidia's leading GeForce GPU the
GTX 1080 Ti it would be nice to see Vega
updates that include higher-end SKUs and
perhaps more affordable mid-range
options as well considering we got the
NES classic in 2016 and the SNES classic
in 2017 it stands to reason that we'll
get an n64 Classic in 2018 or at least
we hope all the answers for didn't
feature the deepest game library in
existence produce gems like super mario
64 mario kart 64 mario party and the
legend of zelda ocarina of time the n64
also suffered from framerate dips but if
Nintendo could release a tiny version of
the console Liar n--'s out the
performance issues so that all of its
games would run at a consistent 60fps
that would be amazing it should of
course also support for controllers
when Microsoft initially revealed the
hololens in 2015 the AR headset showed
tremendous potential it was able to
project believable tracked Holograms
into living rooms without the need for
external sensors this meant you could
see a little Minecraft cave edged into a
wall or see virtual characters walking
around a real house
unfortunately the headset has only been
sold as death kits for $3,000 we also
haven't heard much from Microsoft about
it since
hopefully 2018 will be the year
Microsoft's AR headset takes a
resurgence and releases to consumers so
those are our picks for what we want to
see in 2018 what do you think let us
know in the comments below thank you for
watching
[Music]